[Laughter]
The Invisible Man
should be seen look at that look at that
Oh God sometimes I impressed myself you
know who else impresses me Lee why now
this is the remake of holloman excited
to talk about this movie you know when I
saw the trailer for this film very
confident this would be a really cool
movie my one concern and I want to get
this out of the way immediately my one
concern was that the trailer show you
way too much while I will concede that I
still feel like they could have dialed
it back because sometimes there were
plot points that occur I was like oh
yeah I forgot I saw that in the trailer
but now I know what's gonna happen next
there are still a lot of surprises in
this movie overall I think it is a tense
film it is a scary movie the
performances are great visually really
well done in the first two thirds of the
movie I'd say are done in a really
subtle manner which to do the Invisible
Man I think is the smartest way to do it
the film I think toys a lot with
perspective toys a lot with expectation
versus the outcome there are a lot of
times this movie were like oh well now
this happened so I know what's gonna
happen then no it doesn't go down the
way how a lot of how I thought things
would go down bottom line thoughts
I know people click off reviews early so
I sort of make sure I got the gist of
everything out of the way yeah before we
hop into details Johnny yeah I thought
this was really terrific too and I was
glad that they really decided to go all
in and make a monster film out of this
that encompasses you know the
science-fiction I feel like the thing
that
the trailers don't give away too much of
his the context there's a lot of rich
context like there's no detail that's
left uncolored and yeah it's a really
smart take on the story that fits this
time that justifies its existence the
style just everything in the physical
elements of the movie that come together
to make it are really complementary to
the central premise all the monster
stuff has sort of a unified iconography
that I think is really impressive in a
subtle way this had my heart rate
percolating like the entire movie which
hasn't happened in a while you know like
there are a lot of horror movies I
appreciate but it's been a little while
since a movie had me this nervous the
entire time looking around all the
backgrounds also great used to sound in
this like it I think that's you brought
that up you play it subtle for a while
because yeah it gives you a chance in
your own mind to start living in the
shoes of the character and fearing where
and when and how he's gonna show up you
know yeah because the big backdrop of
this is domestic violence abuse survivor
lingering traumatic residual
repercussions what have you having to
endure a relationship like that the
suffering lingering trauma of how that
alters so much your perspective on
everything around you and I think the
film does an excellent job at that like
yeah it's called the Invisible Man
it's from Universal you know it's an
actual Invisible Man the trailers really
do you in on that even before we get to
the Invisible Man stuff I don't want to
give anything away there's some really
tense stuff that goes on in here that
has nothing to do with the invisible
part with how they handle the Invisible
Man elements I thought was cool because
I think a lot of time with a movie like
this you might expect to hop into the
point of view of the Invisible Man and
watch him stalking kind of like Holloman
well in the original original HG Wells
story is is not the same exact kind of
horror tale but it is about you know a
scientist trying to breakthroughs yeah
in the book he's a mad scientist already
in the movie he's sympathetic and then
becomes mad yeah you don't really get to
know him you only know him from Cecelia
Elizabeth Moss's character her
perspective on it a lot of the POV shots
going to her vision a lot of the time
what this one does visually that's I
think very cool you brought over when we
were watching that kind of like haunting
at Hill House where you start looking at
frames and going is something moving
there is something did that move did
that be right
makes you paranoid with her and I think
that alleviates some of the element of
we know that it's an invisible man and
she's not actually crazy and I think
like it's a really great character
driven movie Elisabeth Moss you get an
actress like her you want to give her a
really great character and here she gets
so much opportunity to shine the amount
of nuance she brings of his role some
just great character scenes that are
given to her while her journeys starting
off as a victim yeah you know where her
journey will eventually go but it's not
about the destination necessarily even
though the destination in this film was
very important and film is so grounded
like this is such a science fiction
ridiculous idea you know an invisible
man who's figured out how to do this
somehow the way the writing is done with
her character it's so expertly crafted
that you're like this is probably the
realistic version of how she would go
through this really fine impressive I
gotta give two sets of props because in
a way I mean you know the original
Invisible Man is a well revered film but
it is different from the original HG
Wells story and I think it's interesting
that Leigh Whannell took it back to this
guy's already screwed us so we see it
from a different perspective but I also
have to give huge props to Elisabeth
Moss because this is true of other work
she's been in and definitely of this
movie from the interviews I've read as
she actually it was very integral in
shaping the character and ago she and
Leigh Whannell would often have scenes
rewritten that they dissected together
he basically said he wanted her and once
she was cast he was like I need you to
kind of help me put the I like make this
character lived in yeah because while
there is like suspenseful moments that
are done visually so well that are just
flat-out sometimes really scary with the
Invisible Man a big part especially
within I would say the first half of
this movie that makes it so effective
you're watching how the Invisible Man is
actually psychologically destroying her
internally before real physical stuff
actually starts going down yeah and
that's what adds so much extra weight
you're watching I don't wanna go into
details because this is stuff that's not
in the trailer it's the effect that it
has on her relationships I don't mean
just like on her like girlfriend
crossbow everyone she she personally
interacts with the great use of music
here too
chillin school that mixes both very
modern sounds and very classic monster
movie sounds which I appreciate it I
also think this movie is dealing with a
lot of you know rather very sensitive
subject material that could have just
ended up being a rather generic take
because I'm someone who's actually
against the whole like sexual assault
trope and now she's strong and I think
the way this movie handles the trauma is
done rather tastefully so I actually
didn't know what he just told me until
right now about Elisabeth Moss working
directly Willy went out to flesh out
this character yeah and I think that's
why it's handled so well yeah because
there are certain things that are true
that thrown in here that certain reveals
that you find out oh that is so
disturbing but it's not done to be like
ya know look at the Invisible Man is go
get him now because now you feel sorry
for her because it's not about doing
that layer for cheap effect which I
think a lot of movies usually do with
female characters who are going up
against the the man who wronged them a
lot of other movies don't give that the
actual nuance to wait they just take the
bright shiny you know oh here's the
horrific thing and they throw it at you
this really unpacks all that horror and
that's the thing is the monster is built
off of so much more than just brute
force and menace yeah
and I think it's really cool how you
know if you've seen Lee one else upgrade
he really figured out a visual flair for
action sequences it's cool to see him
apply a lot of what he tinkered with
there in certain moments but really go
back to his roots of horror sometimes we
were watching like a really visually
cool sequence I'm kind of just caught up
in that yeah but there are times like no
the scene is still really tense yeah and
I'm really happy for him because you
know I've been a big fan since the first
Saw movie of both him and James Bond and
when he started to direct I was just
curious as to how that would take shape
this is I believe his third directing
feature and I appreciate that his style
and his grip on the rest of the
affections of filmmaking it really seems
to have confidently grown over time
because upgrade was a big surprise it
was like oh wow this is so cool and
punchy and then this movie kind of like
insidious did with saw really pulls it
back into the very deliberate restrained
style and so you know the flashes of
violence and things like that are a lot
more bold and Vivian because of that
well his tone and pacing is something
that I love the best way I'd sum it up I
brought this up before like there tends
to be two kind of horror films now which
is like there's the a24 one usually very
character-driven slow
Oh deliberately paste it's not really
big on the thrills I feel like maybe way
late into the fun then you got like your
you know your your conjuring you know
nuns group it's you got like popcorn
horror and then you got independent
horror and I think what he's done here
is perfectly fuse behind us both because
this film is not necessarily like fast
paced for a lot of it but it's always
really intriguing and really
entertaining and keeps you on edge
despite the fact of how the pacing
surprised me because you know you hear
Universal is probably to be like a fast
paced thriller and it's not that a
post-credits scene with Tom Cruise in
the a couple a couple just stray
thoughts to is going back to your point
about your growth as a character like I
appreciated that you really do feel her
grow over time like it's a really solid
arc I think doesn't just start out as a
traditional horror movie centerpiece you
watch her grow and and have to figure
things out as her life and the people in
it are whittled down which I thought was
really nice and that's one thing that
Leigh Whannell said was kind of
important in the script to him was to
have her grow that strength and find it
over time instead of just having like an
aha moment that's like oh yeah go get
him now yeah she's pushed to grow and
the other thing I gotta give huge props
to is just the opening I feel like
openings are tricky to make very
striking and a lot of times I'll find
myself in movies being like okay I
needed a few minutes to find the stride
but this movie has such a bold and
gripping opening I just I feel the need
to point yeah because there's not even
dialogue for a good while yeah I mean
this movie knows how to make great use
of silence there's not a lot of jump
scares there's a couple of moments that
make you jump that are not even at jump
scares and I think that's what's cool
paranoid the whole time yeah yeah there
are moments where the whole crowd pulls
you into this place where the point
isn't just going okay where's the jump
coming where's the loud sound and like
what's it gonna be when is it when where
and how and like yeah it makes you
question so much more that by the time
the jump comes you're off your guard
more than you normally would be I think
I do want to give props to like Aldous
Hodge I thought he was really
charismatic and really sincere warm read
I thought was great too the character
who plays
my sister Harriet dyers the actress
Oliver Jackson Cohen is I won't say much
but when he's there is good the guy
plays the invisible man's brother he's
an actual like character in the film the
songs I'm spoiler Michael Dorman doesn't
really affect urge every kind of has a
little bit of a Michael Shannon thing
about it Michael Shannon meets Dane
DeHaan or something I really hope more
people watches I'm glad they made this
movie for only like seven million
dollars because it probably has a good
chance of making its way my friends and
I hope a lot of people watch this
because this is if there are some dark
universe forming this is the rights this
is the way to do it yeah alright guys
what do you think of the Invisible Man
leave your thoughts down below what's
the next Universal movie plumb house
slice tea you want to see them take on
which character Frankenstein leave your
thoughts down below subscribe to the
reel rejects click the notification bell
and there are patrons who are pledged
for a reward tier where you get to
access to our deleted takes exclusive
patreon lend story some behind the
scenes stuff we're putting together like
sketches or whatever and also we'd like
to do some named call-outs for these
guys we did some at the beginning of the
month and then now since we're at the
end of the month which probably shout
out the rest and those people are Ryan
Beatty rue surname unimportant recently
pledged Kenny Walters and our boy Jeffy
evgeniy Khurana thank you guys and girls
if any of you are girls for pledging our
patreon page hope you're having a good
time over there thank you so much for
being who you are gang who's that behind
you what do you do I'm trying to mess
with Blue's Clues